[Musique]
étranger
trois jours maintenant nous sommes venus ici la semaine dernière
vendredi
le moteur de la ville se déplaçait aujourd'hui mardi c'est pourquoi le moteur il n'y a pas de moteur
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas bouger
donc nous sommes ici aujourd'hui j'étais comme wow
regarde moi
et sois sûr que je peux regarder  mon corps et
tout ce que
vous savez, vous ne pouvez pas prendre votre bain
et vous ne pouvez pas aimer parce qu'il n'y a pas
de maisons où vous pouvez changer vos
vêtements et des choses comme ça
et aussi de l'argent pour manger,
vous voyez,
mais ma seule chose est que je veux toujours juste
acheter
le gouvernement
pour nous considérer
que nous traversons
au moins pour nous aider
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
étranger
[Musique]
toi